il ya quelques années j'ai découvert à
la bibliothèque nationale
france un livre intitulé cheval en place
ce que bon leur et blanc excuse de
bourbon publié en allemagne en 1848 le
livre et son auteur
gustav holst nam ont marqué était
totalement inconnu à la réunion en
métropole en allemagne au fil des amis
les recherches menées aux archives ont
fait découvrir un franco allemand qui a
été à bourbon entre 1842 et 1845
rédacteur en chef de la feuille
hebdomadaire professeur d'histoire et de
philosophie au collège royal secrétaire
au conseil coloniale et fondateur de
l'institut coloniale pour l'instruction
de la population défavorisée dans le
cadre de ses fonctions
la monarque et s'est investi dans les
mesures préventives à l'émancipation des
esclaves